CHUMLEE: What do you have here?
CHRIS: I have a pair of
brass duck foot pistols.
CHUMLEE: Wow, those
are pretty cool.
CHRIS: These are
volley pistols that
were made for a British Naval
officer in the 18th century.
CHUMLEE: Mind if I grab one?
CHRIS: Go right ahead.
CHUMLEE: I see where they
call them, uh, duck foot.
Looks like a little duck foot--
CHRIS: It does.
CHUMLEE: --swimming
through the water.
Even though I'm not supposed
to deal with high priced items,
these guns are some of the
coolest things that I've
seen coming into the shop.
I can't let this guy walk.
It's time to prove Rick,
he's not the only one
that can wheel and deal.
What do you want
to do with them?
CHRIS: I'd like to sell them.
CHUMLEE: OK, how much are
you looking to get for them?
I'm interested.
CHRIS: I'm asking $50,000.
$50,000?
Um, I mean, it
could be possible.
If you let me take these to
the gun range and fire them.
I'm fine with that.
I-- I'd like to fire them, too.
- All right.
Well, you got time today?
CHRIS: I'm free all afternoon.
CHUMLEE: All right.
We'll meet at the gun range, in
say, about an hour and a half?
OK.
That sounds good to me.
All right.
I'll write the
address down, home.
I'll be right back.
CHRIS: OK.
I think once we get
out on the range
and he actually
fires them, I think
we're going to make a deal.
RICK: Well, you guys
look really busy.
Oh, just-- I was waiting
for you to get back, actually.
I got to take the rest
the day out of the shop.
But I'm still going
to be working.
RICK: Oh, shi-- what
are you going to do?
CHUMLEE: I just-- I'm
about to go purchase a gun,
duck foot pistol.
I need to go make sure it works.
I told the guy to
meet me at the range.
RICK: And how much are
you going to buy this for?
Well, he said $50, but he
was just throwing in an--
- $50?
- Thousand.
But he was throwing
an amount there.
COREY: OK.
I'm definitely going
with you, then.
CHUMLEE: No, I got it.
I'm going with you,
I don't worry, man.
CHUMLEE: No, I got this.
Trust me.
RICK: I will meet
you guys out there.
COREY: Wha--
RICK: I was more or less forced
to come out of the gun range,
because Chum set up a time
to meet him at the range
and test them out.
I asked Alex to come
down to meet us,
because I need a second
opinion, because I unequivocally
do not trust Chum.
So what do we got here?
I have a pristine pair
of duck's foot pistols.
COREY: Whoa.
RICK: Well, those are cool.
COREY: Wow.
Check that out.
RICK: Wow, Chum, you actually
didn't screw this up.
CHUMLEE: Told you.
ALEX: The real term for
this is a volley pistol.
And the reason they
designed this, though--
it was for crowd control.
So any time that you might
have a mass of people
trying to get you,
you would want
to volley pistol in your hand.
RICK: Oh, wow.
ALEX: And look, you guys
see that mark, has a V
and there's crown over it?
COREY: Yeah.
Those are British proof marks.
Basically, they passed a law,
because they didn't want gun
makers making bad guns
that would blow up and kill
people who are firing them.
So in England, any
time you made a gun,
you had to submit it
to the proof house.
They would put three
times the amount of powder
in it that it was supposed
to be able to handle.
If it didn't blow up,
they stamped it with a V
with the crown-- means viewed.
So each of these
barrel is viewed.
That's a really good sign.
COREY: Sweet.
RICK: OK.
So, um-- it's all right
with you if we shoot them?
Yes.
Go right ahead.
RICK: All right.
Well, load them up.
ALEX: All right, Chum.
That is cocked
and ready to fire.
Corey?
COREY: Chum, you're first.
[muffled gunshots]
[laughter]
RICK: Chum's didn't
all fire at once.
They went bup-bup-bup.
ALEX: Yup.
Me now?
[muffled gunshots]
[laughter]
COREY: That was, uh, not
what I was expecting at all.
ALEX: (LAUGHING)
COREY: Did I hit anything?
ALEX: Yeah.
Yeah, you got hit.
Here, and you got there.
That's two, three, four.
COREY: Oh, wow.
ALEX: Chum got-- one--
RICK: You had four barrels,
and you shot the target once.
CHUMLEE: What?
[laughter]
COREY: So, I mean,
I know they're cool,
but what are they worth?
They're the real deal.
They're rare, they're really
early, by a known maker,
and they fire.
These are not
inexpensive pistols
I value them at $45,000.
(SIGHS IN RELIEF)
COREY: OK, um--
well, man, I really
appreciate you coming down.
- You're welcome.
Good luck.
Nice to meet you.
Thank you.
ALEX: There's a huge market
for duck's foot pistols.
I do think it's worth it for
the shop to purchase them,
because they're never going
to see a pair like this again.
So what are you looking
to get out of them?
I was looking to get $50,000.
(SIGHS) You know
I can't pay that.
Um-- I'm more in the
$20-- $20,000 range.
Could you come down
a little bit, or--
Would you accept $40,000?
I'll tell you what, man, uh--
I could do $30 grand.
That's the most I can do.
CHRIS: Would you do $35,000?
I-- I wouldn't.
$30 grand's what I can do.
Sorry, I can't take
anything less than $35,000.
Well, I appreciate it, my man.
CHRIS: Thank you.
Maybe next time.
Take care.
CHRIS: I wasn't able
to make a deal today
with the volley
pistols, but, you
know, I think that
I'm going to have
to fend off a whole
crowd of buyers,
once I get them back out there.